welcome to minecraft dungeons let's
build the pyramids Jackie yeah where are
the pyramids gone we're good pop where's
ed smack him alright smacking good I've
already mastered the game thank you okay
and then right-click him shoot him in
the back okay and then you can do like
what
oh hell yeah it's like Dark Souls oh why
don't I do supplies here we for new
missions where are we going I don't know
let's start any of them pumpkin pastures
why not let's freakin do this I want a
cool armor like you have ain't fair me
you'll get it don't worry about it
alright what's very good where you see
this better be exactly like Minecraft
yes they have roasted
that's what the villagers did they the
Vikings they just roasted exactly like
Minecraft oh my god oh yeah yeah alright
no epic battle happen here oh my god
50,000 people used to live here and now
it's a ghost town there you go instance
loot yo greedy I came for them my
minecraft guild look at these grass that
looks so good they nailed you think that
grass is ray-traced
oh it would look way better if it was
alright so are we gonna build get some
wood or build our first villager yeah
we're gonna head we're gonna kill ender
dragon to this episode in the game yeah
I was singing yeah and the map over here
nothing Witcher where does it call the
the wither wither yeah no it's a bow
remaining stop taking everything bug
that are you want you want okay yeah
drop a bomb
yeah drop the flipping butt bro wait
what is this hello that's scary
really pretty epic yeah
oh whoa this is cool whoa can we go
there
no not yet oh I'm invincible and have an
arrow through my skull another one I
mean Jackie take them out pull them I
get it
dude their secrets over here what is
this another secret I find another
secret Jack I'll teleport to a bush is
this what you find yeah okay that's
kinda cool damn it back in the days I
wasn't allowed in any guilt because I I
rolled greed on all the items and they
got his suspect many different it wasn't
my ball
I hadn't rolled greed on every item that
rolled and people were already fed up
and then this super rare like fire
assistant that was really useful dropped
and everyone just freaked out like
everyone rolled on it and of course I
want it and everyone was just so done
like a pig man from behind nice naturals
I'm just saying bro just cuz my head has
two faces doesn't mean you can make me
how do you do it you gotta shoot the
creepers right yeah that makes sense
yeah pretty easy though how are you
spelling out I like the Hat they go boom
they go boom boom I like sweet take that
you stink steam wait am i nose
ALPA laughs hey bruh I'm kind of
confused by this game likewise is
minecraft Diablo minecraft cuz it's epic
okay epic yeah yeah
I feel like I would get addicted to this
very easy but really I guess is like
thank you co-op dungeon-crawler
it's always fun not to cow oh this is so
she'll go oh hell mine okay weights a
trap it's a trap jack wait am i guess a
trap has some kegs I get all the I get
all the loot no are you getting stuff as
well
let me check inventory no I got stuff
okay I made it very democratic he can't
steal my stuff alright fair enough
can you stop doing that that's just what
happens when you pick up the TNT all
right you're right clicking you go boom
all right that's our plan you go in and
go boom and brush a roustabout a car
basically what we did in regular
minecraft anyway we just made fun of all
our enemies okay go in go boom go boom
you did it that was awesome
foosh I feel like you should have saved
that but okay what sponsor eagle in the
shadows I see it like I got soft potato
man an epic rap battle went down here
dude you go to heel press e I know that
yeah what is this
what a say ah yeah oh also he's making
this alright got it that's cool yeah oh
god whooping him stop I'm gonna fight
your wither yeah me too
you're again statue mmm I looked up the
reviews of the game and one of the
tongue top negative reviews was saying
there's nothing mining and there's
nothing crafting in this game I mean can
you argue with this I can argue with
facts and logic like that destroy this
droid I'm sure it's gonna get more
difficult it is a kids game after all
and we are big men and we are big
hey speaks for yourself okay I am an
epic Viking roasting villages you gotta
have the Viking look now you're bald
well so you do you bro you got the Irish
haha bald you're the bald one no I have
more higher than you will ever know
what are you talking all right just
because you have more beard hair does
not mean you have more hair overall no
that's how that counts it all cancels
out just see my leg hair and you'll know
what I'm talking about see my
undercarriage okay alright you know how
I don't it didn't say stuff that was on
my mind Jack you should do that team no
I don't hate PG like your stinky videos
uh-huh like your blinky videos are so
stinky it doesn't even work anyway
try being PG for like a month and I was
like oh you didn't go up oh really
yeah I didn't I just did it because
that's who I am as a person
nice just hey hey hey me coming coming
are you doing oh god I don't mean to
kill it damn it why'd you kill the Sheep
I didn't mean to we were gonna live
together you go in the water by the way
look what you can't do that in mine
crying I know changing the game actually
you can't feel like zoomed up I know
that was a joke for fortnight why when
the chapter two came out and you were
able to go in the water and swim yeah I
was like oh no game has ever had
swimming before actually okay
volker oh it's done here I hate this
Zelda ass music no it isn't Oh get the
TNT and throw it at him oh it's mine on
the tree good
ah I kill him with kindness mess him up
oh look at him hiding yeah right you're
no match for my strength potion huh and
your baldness okay don't kill the show
you were talking about here in the in
the game yeah what are you thinking cuz
you're bald in real life I'm not it's
going out like hairline gang all right
you're not getting this on potato
screw you you kill a sheep no I didn't
no I did not I think not hit here I
didn't I how many times have you watched
the room now maybe seven times my god
seen it twice it's a classic
well it's times were with you okay wait
wait wait wait Jack what are you doing
so I got an artifact whoa yeah you
equipped that bra what do I do but Mayan
artifact lets me shoot fireworks whoo
that's not a firework see ya wow that
was so cool oh cool
dude I got shingles you've got akimbo
tickles
I got freakin akimbo Sega's right oh
look it's Animal Crossing do they have
any recipes you know people said that in
honor of me might you breakin my
tambourine you should you should way I
polish your bell hold on me breaking
your tambourine yeah yeah I'm I thought
you're a child excuse me
no I won't if all right speedran did you
see that Guinness World Records are
trying to fan speed runs from YouTube
what do you mean vanning they're they're
like copyright striking everybody and
try to remove the videos because
Guinness think that they should be the
only ones that have World Records are
you [ __ ] kidding me
I saw it on reddit I think I didn't dive
into really far so I just assumed
it's very dumb how do you so they
copyrighted the world what do you think
they copyrighted I think they just well
maybe they have and it tightens the
souls of the dead before releasing them
into a closed check check check
someone mama got a mercenary armor Oh
brah you want a fashion show boom
Oh stupid this one looks cool all right
connects mission whoa man whoa I feel
like I'm doing everything this doesn't
feel fair
we shouldn't be sharing the learn from
that 164 displayed okay I'll take sixty
actually I think the llama is doing the
most so he didn't really know he's not
doing anything
I didn't realize I had this got him got
him messed him up he's scared now
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what whoa
you venom clay whoa don't you know come
to get it jelly I'm jelly you don't get
it yeah you get Sven me Benny
I guess what lady lay I do have fire
arrows now sink
at least Sam does what does the llama do
I have to read it
oh he spits he's got reindeer mitts just
like his father
oh just like son to me he's like and
he's like father to my son name is Sam
seven dare you how about fencing No did
you go to expensive because he spends on
yeah yeah I don't mind Sampson without
knowing that you did that
wired somebody over at juncture linings
I don't know told you be sure one brains
oh that's a hive mind you tube hide mine
one brain cell all needed sets mob on
fire for three seconds I do five damage
per second I nearly got that too on my
poisonous one that makes no sense okay
whatever
yeah I have it to Jack I can say you
screenshot later it's like the brother
being like yeah yeah I did it too I
thought I got it the first it got that
Daniel Lama this slimy swampy suck
Rami might die llamas tanking he's
healing you oh god there's so many slime
you can't die in a kids game come on oh
yeah yeah oh nice look at my hat look at
the size of my head
love my back oh no Sam died you can
reach me back he back oh well here's new
I think it's actually just doesn't make
joke jack say hi to new friend and cape
you have a chicken oh you are full
chicken I'm chicken salty
if you should check cosmetic you might
have it too then I feel I feel
indifferent wearing this I don't know if
I want to be wearing this man Ian's head
okay so I collect the souls and then I
can use this kill them
Gilly you can summon him I can't you can
see me soon I can summon got it got it
too bad mom loves me more
no I'm the favorite choice take that
bang I'm the one with the poison
cleavage wait what well your talk cuz
your mom's Lee's favorite no no mom said
privately that she might turn on the
Minecraft mom said I'm better at
minecraft than you no no that's too far
man
yeah she's joking before mom says my
llama really cool victory I remember
when I was a kid my friend Victor had a
he bought a shirt that said victory on
it and he thought it was too cool
and I'm not gonna lie I thought it was
cool too I'm not gonna lie I wish he got
the YouTube channel Oh Gilly
kill the monster spawn we have just kept
that and leveled up oh that's I thought
of that in my head before you said it
what does my thing do nothing because
you're bad thank you I walked right into
that
no my friend oh this is say this is a
shame mama this is low level players are
you to break the spell we save you them
free watch this watch is yeah 400
million dollars 400 million we could
retire we don't have to play Minecraft
anymore so what do you want to do buy
our own Island and play Minecraft on a
Minecraft IRL hey nice oh that sounds
like a mr. B's video I feel like there's
a deep message here about poisoning the
minds of workers and make them we're
saving them everybody else poison them
but it says a lot about life can't wait
oh no Felix Felix it's lava oh we did so
much damage right away thank him Oh tank
n oh oh good stop run away god damn it
okay
go check your ball thank you up all my
arrows edson mine is mine it's mine
credit it alright well thanks guys for
watching check out jacksepticeye on
YouTube subscribers
[Music]
[Applause]